- Bonsoir.
- Il faut s'attendre à ce que
plusieurs biens de consommation
et un prix qui augmente au cours
des prochaines semaines?
- Oui tout ce qu'on importe par
conteneur, c'est-à-dire plein de
produits de consommation, des
vêtements ville des meubles, des
équipements de jardin terrain
etc. ce sont des produits de
consommation courante qui sont
touchées par cette hausse des
coûts de transport.
Tout ce qui provient d'Asie et
de Chine mais aussi d'Europe va
être touchée par ses coûts de
transport.
- Comment on explique cette
rareté de conteneurs et cette
augmentation des coûts pour
faire de l'importation?
- Tout a débuté avec le début de
la pandémie. En Asie et en Chine
où on a dû eu des arrêts de
production. Par la suite on a
repris en Chine mais c'est
l'Europe qui a été touchée et
ensuite l'Amérique.
On recevait des conteneurs avec
des biens, des équipements, des
pièces, et c'est conteneurs
accumulés dans des ports, des
cours de manufacturier, parce
que les entreprises étaient
fermées et étaient obligées de
cesser leurs activités.
On s'est retrouvé avec un
retard, un cumul de conteneurs
et par le temps qu'on a réussi à
les vider, le problème était
déjà grave. Chez les
exportateurs et les expéditeurs
on était à court de ces
conteneurs vide pour être
capable de les remplir et de
réapprovisionner.
Ajoutez à cela en deuxième
partie de l'an dernier une
augmentation subite de la
demande. Les gens comme vous
savez ne pouvez plus voyager, ne
pouvait plus aller au
restaurant, ils se sont mis à
investir dans la rénovation,
dans l'achat de meubles, dans
l'achat d'équipements de jardin
et ainsi de suite. Beaucoup de
ces produits sont importés. Une
hausse importante de la demande
avec une pénurie, une baisse
dans l'incapacité, c'est la
recette parfaite pour une
augmentation des coûts car le
transport maritime c'est un des
secteurs où le jeu de l'offre et
de la demande fonctionne à peu
près parfaitement. Lorsque la
capacité diminue, la demande
augmente, c'est clair qu'il y
aura des augmentations de
tarifs.
- Au bout c'est le consommateur
qui va payer ses augmentation
là?
- Au bout de la chaîne
effectivement c'est le
consommateur qui va payer une
bonne partie. On a vu dans votre
reportage que certains
intermédiaires ont tenté de
réduire la facture mais ce ne
sera pas évident. Je peux
ajouter, ce n'est pas juste le
transport maritime. Transport
aérien a vécu la même chose l'an
dernier, les transports ont
doublé car il y a une baisse
subite de la capacité de
transport.
Même si on cherche à utiliser le
transport aérien au lieu de
maritime on ferait face au même
genre de problème.
- Quand vous parlez
d'augmentation de tarifs, de
coûts, on parle de quel ordre?
- Les gens de la SAQ, on s'en
tire assez bien avec une
augmentation de 80 %. Il y a des
indices qui nous montrent que ça
pourrait tripler au cas de repli
pour certains marchés.
Ce n'est pas exceptionnel, on a
vu ça au début des années 2000
avec la croissance des
exportations de Chine. Des
diminutions aussi subites après
un ralentissement économique en
deux mil 8 août 2009.
Il y a beaucoup de volatilité
dans ce marché là.
On peut souhaiter que ça va se
calmer un peu et que les tarifs
vont diminuer avec
l'augmentation de la capacité et
l'arrivée de nouveaux conteneurs
qu'on est en train de fabriquer
et de nouveaux navires.
- Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
solutions envisageables pour les
importateurs pour minimiser
cette flambée des prix?
- On pensa la possibilité de
fabriquer localement. Ça peut
faire parti de la solution. Ce
n'est pas nécessairement une
solution pour tout le monde.
Bien souvent il faut avoir
recours à l'automatisation, la
robotisation pour réduire les
coûts suffisamment et on a peut-
être pas les volumes qui
permettent d'abaisser les tarifs
de production.
Je pense qu'on va devoir
continuer de vivre dans une
économie mondialisée.
- Acheter local aussi j'imagine?
- Ça peut faire parti de la
solution à court terme.
- Est-ce qu'il y a des pénuries
à prévoir selon ce que vous
voyez?
- Beaucoup de retard. Je connais
des gens qui attendent leur
équipement de jardin et ne
l'auront pas avant la fin de
l'été. D'autres attendent des
électroménagers. Tous les
secteurs à peu près sont
touchés.
Ça va finir par arriver mais ça
risque d'être un peu tard pour
certains.
- Avez-vous une idée de combien
de temps ça pourrait durer tout
ça?
- Très difficile à prévoir.
C'est, comme vous disiez, s'il y
a des ajustements dans la
demande, ça demande commence à
diminuer car les gens
recommencent à voyager ça peut
s'atténuer dans les prochains
mois ou dans la prochaine année.
- Avoir... entre-temps on va
certainement payer des
augmentations. On parlait de la
SAQ mais dans divers biens de
consommation que l'on retrouve